dites vous la terre et une serpillière
non je dire là c'est trop tendance à
prendre la terre pour les séries en
bourse à tout le monde
la seule chose c'est qu'on n'a pas
forcément encore conscience de l'impact
et des effets que ça va voir quoi que ça
chagrine pas forcément le tout le monde
parce que on se dit que la terre ait une
capacité de régénération absolue et
qu'elle va se débrouiller avec ce qu'on
lui inflige ce qui peut être vrai à une
échelle de temps très très très longue
l'échelle géologique mais pas les
cheveux à notre échelle et qu'il ya un
moment où elle va elle va agoniser et
c'est nouveau mais lieux qui seront les
premiers visés
c'est ce qu'il faut essayer de moi je
fais partie de ceux qui essayent
d'expliquer aux gens que la nature n'a
pas de capacité de régénération absolue
que nous sommes nous sommes partie
prenante de la nature on appartient à l
est que si on l'alter c'est tout
simplement notre avenir notre futur
qu'on met en cause c'est pas des
échelles de temps très loin c'est sur
les prochaines décennies aujourd'hui on
a encore les cartes de notre destin en
main mais c'est un problème de
conscience et concrètement qu'est-ce qui
est qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce que la
fondation trek est à nous la font de
rennes où on est là justement pour
expliquer fia pour éduquer les jeunes et
les moins jeunes ont fait on fabrique
des outils pédagogiques en fabrique des
programmes on aide les gens à agir
concrètement en faveur de
l'environnement
et puis par ailleurs on essaie dans les
milieux industriels politiques de faire
en sorte que les gens comprennent qu'il
ya une urgence c'est lourd ces
partenariats pas peu de le dire